life is movement at figures those games
we don't great just characters weren't
you create this living breathing entity
the animation is a big man of that
motion capture is the right time
consuming expensive process especially
for us in G studios we are lucky to work
be working with the best actors and
peeves in the world right now we want to
brake line animation to the next level
Kim developers haven't given it the
attention it deserves and we want to be
the ones who capture that magic again
take the shafts of the most toys like
these sessions have been great we got
such a high quality materials for an
hour right now we're just get back to
our student in turn it into a swine
match we'd like to give a huge thank you
to all of you Kickstarter backers with
all those pledges we will be here today
all the Kickstarter money will be
invested into big motion capture and we
believe the fans will definitely see the
value in that you're a natural ah the
adventure is eight ER oh the
possibilities an adventure game like
you've never seen before play our levels
and puzzles laughs and our story then
create your own levels and puzzles then
play someone else's story and steal
their ideas then create more levels in
this time and a cutscene then become a
famous adventurer creator and make a lot
of money somehow and forget all of your
old friends because you have rich
friends now but don't forget to vote for
us on green light or your life will keep
on being miserable thanks for watching
grandpa Mike out